[Música]
y comenzamos de esta manera del repaso
por toda la prensa internacional ya está
conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez más de
burros a bienvenida a feliz inicio de
semana feliz lunes muy buen día vamos a
comenzar entonces hablando lo que
estamos avanzando el 'new york times'
porque mientras estados unidos busca
espía chinos científicos universitarios
advierten sobre reacciones violentas
rosa qué está pasando con esto este es
un artículo raúl que se centra en un
caso del 'doctor who' para comentar algo
que está sucediendo según esta
periodista a escala de todo eeuu y esa
digamos la obsesión de las agencias
estadounidenses como el fbi en sospechar
de distintos académicos de orígenes
chinos de estar trabajando para el
gobierno de beijing y como comentábamos
este artículo empieza por el caso del
'doctor who' que estuvo perseguido
durante dos años por el fbi de hecho
estuvo también dos años en arresto
domiciliario sin sueldo y sin poder
trabajar sin embargo este septiembre un
juez acabó absorbiéndolos de todos los
cargos por considerar que no había
pruebas sólida sea contra él pero más
allá de ser un caso aislado este es la
historia que están viviendo muchos
académicos en estados unidos y este
artículo lo relaciona con la
implantación de la llamada iniciativa
china que surgió bajo la administración
de donald trump y continúa a día de hoy
bajo este gobierno de bailén de hecho la
periodista señala que tras hablar con a
muchos académicos chinos la imagen a la
que se proyecta es la de una comunidad
aterrada de hecho pues como comentábamos
muchos académicos chinos señalan por
ejemplo que se sienten humillados porque
las capacitaciones que ellos se tienen
que seguir sobre la injerencia
extranjera la mayoría de ejemplos son
solamente sobre científicos infiltrados
de origen chino también denuncian
retrasos inexplicables para renovar los
visados y para terminar un poco con este
tema pues muchos académicos acerca de
2000 han escrito distintas cartas para
mandarlas a las agencias federales
denunciando que no tiene sentido
perseguir a cada y cause pues las
investigaciones académicas no están
clasificadas y al mismo tiempo acaban en
general siendo publicadas y esto sucede
en paralelo en que china está viviendo
lo que se llama pues una vuelta de
cerebros no en que muchos académicos que
estaban trabajando en eeuu vuelven a las
universidades chinas por eso este
artículo señala que esta política de
persecución estadounidense está dañando
al final a la poder académico de
washington vamos ahora a rózsa a
alemania con el ter spiegel las primeras
fracturas es invisibles en berlín esto
de cara a la reciente formación del
nuevo gobierno de coalición que está
pasando sólo a pocos días de rosas ya se
están viendo en la fractura mira lo que
defiende este artículo que está firmado
por 17 periodistas raúl citando pues
muchas anécdotas pues al final como
comentas este gobierno ni tan siquiera
ha empezado a andar pero pues ya a todos
nos gusta comentar y vislumbrar un poco
cuáles pueden ser los obstáculos a los
que se enfrenta esta coalición inédita
no este tripartito que nunca se ha visto
a nivel federal lo que defiende este
artículo es que si bien lo que todo el
mundo esperaba era que los
socialdemócratas y los ecologistas
fueron fueran los aliados naturales
finalmente parece que hay más afinidad
entre los liberales y los
socialdemócratas y para resumir este
largo texto lo que señala este artículo
es que si bien los socialdemócratas van
a estar un tiempo viviendo de la energía
que les inyectó el hecho de recuperar la
cancillería y los liberales van a estar
bien mientras no se suban los impuestos
porque recordemos fueron cuarta fuerza y
tienen un papel importante en las
negociaciones del gobierno los verdes
son los que más difícil lo van a tener
para satisfacer a las bases de su propio
partido pues su principal alemanno y
ambición es una lucha efectiva contra el
cambio climático y esto es lo que pues
más difíciles de conseguir a corto plazo
y en resumen lo que plantea este
artículo es que quien va a acabar
teniendo más peso en el ejecutivo si el
clima o las finanzas si los verdes o los
liberales vamos ahora hablar de xiomara
castró que consolida su ventaja para
convertirse en la próxima presidenta y
honduras eso es un artículo del diario
'el país' rosa si mira este artículo del
país lo que básicamente comenta es a
nivel actual lo que está sucediendo en
honduras pues tras esta jornada de
elecciones presidenciales y viena
comenta por un lado la alta
participación como nos comentaba andrés
casi de un 70 por ciento señala que
xiomara castro en a su discurso pues se
hizo referencia como nos comentaba
también andrés al golpe de estado que
destituyó a su marido en 2009 y que dijo
que con su gobierno se iba a acabar con
el autoritarismo la corrupción el
narcotráfico y los escuadrones de la
muerte y básicamente raúl pues lo que
señala este artículo es un momento
surrealista cuando los dos candidatos
proclamaron a su victoria pero algo que
con el conteo ya se ha acabado ya se ha
acabado pues eso diferenciando vamos a
ver entonces qué pasa en honduras rosell
precisamente vamos a analizar lo que va
a pasar en ese país de tras estas
elecciones del día ayer con esta primera
invita al día